[Música]
las noticias de la salud son con más
Romero sala en directo América mar Buen
día para usted Buenos días Ángela pero
notificó su primer caso de polio en más
de 30 años que se sabe de esto si no
queríamos dejar pasar esta noticia tan
importante que a pesar de que sucedió la
semana pasada cuando no había el espacio
de salud pone un poco la región frente
al espejo en la lucha no cómo avanza la
lucha contra la erradicación por la
erradicación de la polio en este caso de
Perú sabemos que se trata de un niño que
presentó parálisis a finales ya de 2022
Y hasta ahora hubo la confirmación de
que esta parálisis estaba provocada por
el virus de la polio en este caso
derivado de la vacuna ahora explicaremos
más concretamente Qué significa eso Es
un niño de una comunidad indígena que
tiene una cobertura vacunal bastante
baja precisamente él no estaba vacunado
en contra de la polio ni con otras
vacunas incluidas en el esquema regular
para la infancia sabemos que se
encuentra estable sabemos que se
encuentran monitoreado y que las
autoridades peruanas sanitarias
anunciaron un despliegue de vigilancia
epidemiológica para conocer más
escuchemos
dentro de las 12 horas de reportado el
caso un equipo multidisciplinario del
minsa y la gerencia Regional de salud
Loreto se desplazaron a la provincia de
atem del marañón donde realizan la
vigilancia epidemiológica intervenciones
de vacunación como barrido vacunal
contra el apoyo y otras vacunas del
esquema regular y acciones de prevención
en la comunidad indígena donde vive el
menor la polio es algo que parece lejano
de nuestra generación mar que hace
décadas lo recordábamos pero muchos
hemos olvidado su gravedad en los
últimos años Sí precisamente por eso es
pertinente hacer un repaso no de Qué
sucede con esta enfermedad es una
enfermedad provocada por un virus la
mayoría de contagios son asintomáticos
pero en uno de cada 200 casos puede
provocar parálisis afecta al sistema
nervioso y si esta parálisis llega al
tronco llega a los pulmones en ese
sentido puede llegar a provocar la
muerte no afectaba decenas de miles de
personas en el mundo por ejemplo en la
década de los 40 sólo en Estados Unidos
incapacitaba a 35.000 personas cada año
y en el 88 en un momento en el que ya
había una vacuna ya había campañas de
vacunación eran
350.000 los casos que se encontraban
cada año hubo un esfuerzo titánico de
campañas de vacunación para erradicar
esta enfermedad Gracias por cierto
también a que las vacunas de la polio no
fueron patentadas entonces fueron
rápidamente accesibles para muchos las
Américas precisamente fue la primera
región declarada libre de polio en el 94
África fue la última recientemente en el
2020 entonces bueno tenemos en cuenta
todos estos grandes esfuerzos que se
hicieron No hay tres tipos además de
virus vamos a hacer un repaso rápido dos
de ellos se han erradicado uno sigue
siendo endémico solo en Afganistán y
Pakistán y también hay brotes
actualmente de vacunas de virus Perdón
derivados de la vacuna y una vacuna oral
contra la polio que usa virus
debilitados que cabe la posibilidad de
que las personas vacunadas lo desechen y
si es en comunidades donde no hay mucha
cobertura vacunal este virus puede
llegar a fortalecerse y volver a
contagiar a otras personas se considera
delicado no hasta que tanto el
poliovirus salvaje el que existe en
Pakistán y Afganistán como estos
derivados de la vacuna y ya no sucedan
el caso de Perú en todo caso es una
alerta para toda la región sí la OMS
recomienda una tasa de vacunación del
95% para garantizar que no vuelvan a
surgir brotes de polio y los únicos
países de la región que fecha de 2021
cumplen esto son en Chile Costa Rica y
Cuba esto cuando hace 10 años que había
16 países de la región que estaban
cumpliendo con este 95% de cobertura
vacunal vemos algunos casos aquí
Argentina no cumple con esta con esta
con esta tasa está en el 74% Haití con
la situación crítica Crónica tiene un
50% de tasa vacunal y por ejemplo Perú
que es un país del país que nos ha
puesto a hablar de esto está en el 79%
con un declive que vamos viendo
sostenido en la última década a raíz
también del cómic 19 y las
interrupciones que provocó la pandemia
pero también parece que estemos
olvidando la gravedad de esta
la importancia de la vacunación estamos
tirando por la borda años de trabajos de
médicos y de voluntarios por ejemplo
Perú de hecho fue el último país en el
que se encontró un caso de polio en la
región de las Américas y el médico que
halló este caso recuerda como el trabajo
de su vida fue convencer a poblaciones
algunas Rurales algunas indígenas que no
tienen tanta confianza en los sistemas
de salud para que se vacunaran incluso
por ejemplo en contextos armados en Perú
con el conflicto con sendero luminoso
este médico recordaba Cómo iban a todas
estas comunidades a vacunar y ahora con
este resurgimiento parece que todo este
año y años y esfuerzos de trabajo estén
a punto de perderse lo que es
absolutamente lamentable pues Yo le
agradezco mucho y nos vemos la próxima
semana si le parece hasta la próxima
semana Ángela